so you all moved in uh no not really  well if your rooms close to Alex's you  should be careful since she snores like  a truck you wouldn't think it to look at  her but it's like a chainsaw fighting a  pack of wolf can we just stop talking  about this yeah what are we actually  doing tight every year the seniors spend  the night on Edwards Island  it's a kameena high tradition everyone  this is Jonas Alex's new stepbrother  from I already forgot where yeah he's  cool  so be nice oh we won't fight great cool  and somebody changed the station what's  so special about this place the island  was a military forum it's a tourist trap  for morons you want to buy Christmas  ornaments of World War two fast Oh relax  we'll have a good time  come on let's explore hey what's that  see this Islands pretty cool right yep  why would that  you  [Music]  [Music]  does it hurt  [Music]